c'est que quand pardon du peu c'est une
partie de moi donc c'est beaucoup pour
moi puisque très humblement
je suis le président fondateur
un beau soir de du mois de juin quoi
quoi du février 2019 avec bernard payet
mon auto valley du tout seul y'a que moi
dans un cabaret au port et mamady un
texte mettra 5 est endeuillée après les
chante ne démarre comme ça après bien
vite
miral jb avec nounous râle de tourner
avec nous et puis le groupe l'eau
croupie démarre comme ça mais tout ça
passe
noté mme diana faire simple nous dit
nous les créoles une claque mais joli
nouveau défendre nous payer notre
culture qu'on dit ça comme sec de moan
vous venez en temps en temps pas si
maintenant à la place d'un discours
universitaire d'un discours politique où
il est capable sur la scène créer du
beau avec la musique un texte afin qu'un
pas mais comme je dois tout fait de la
prose sans le savoir comme du lot nous
par la goutte l'homme les jolies et les
festayres paris pour faire la gueule il
y est dit des choses magnifiques de la
poésie vous des chocs pas apporte
d'autres choses que ferry la bouche
parce que jusqu'à cette époque là
souvent des fois quand elle était juste
bon pour casser qi pour des sketches
pour atteindre affaire comme ça
maintenant et qu'on d'attention mais
défalé à ce moment là bien montrer que
le créole est une langue capable de dire
le beau le vrai le bien le mal est
d'aborder d'autres gens que le sketch
est nouveau
c'est quoi votre titre préféré
jusqu'à quand
[Musique]
militante romance pour ico ou à l'ompi
bato fou
le spa du moment taxe moines ont
commencé de marcelo -
par le bonne mort cela
seul était capable à la fois d'être très
belle chanson donc une oeuvre artistique
pure
d'être dans un genre où ça au mélange
des apports divers un food créole un
fonds d'afrique un fonds de l'indh à
fond de l'europe et dans le même temps
d'être un texte qui dénonce
qui roule des yeux donc c'est une chance
engagé mais où peut nous fait le pari de
dire qu'une chanson peut être engagée ça
qu'ils soient mauvais donc comment le bo
peut rendre compte du vrai comment la
chanson peut devenir politique sans pour
autant perdre sa qualité de deux textes
et de deux chansons voilà après bon
peut-être dot mais parce c'était un peu
mon
buteur moi à l'époque c'était vraiment
ça c'est au mad dans cet espace de prise
de conscience aux yeux fait comprendre
fait bouger
après +11 chante l'amour mettez fallait
dana et enchante d'abord
parce que
simplement parce n'avait
par rapport à d'autres les yeux bleus ou
verts donc une prise de conscience plus
nette de la situation
se trouve les bons on n'a rien à dire
sur tous les pas bons il faut on a envie
de dire d'envoyer me dire nous té fait
le constat que le pays mette au fond
des filets nous tes bouge et pour
nous-mêmes pour le pays donc c'est en
fait c'est tout les sens de l'engagement
de l'engagement politique ou culturelle
c'est de se dire d'un a fait qui va pas
nous citoyens en temps nous ne
responsable d'un moon qui y est mes
chronos en tenant son nom le pays nous
la bouger la bougie n'a pas n'a pas pas
sur les parois des mandats présidentiels
époque et football par ci par là nadine
ou simplement peut-être un mini robes
aux yeux du monde c'est passe pas ça
passe par la culture passe par la
chanson passe par parle par le spectacle
parce qu'on me croit beaucoup
dans cette idée que la culture est aussi
un moteur
qui éveille les consciences
c'est pas un amusement sa patte un
amusement bien sûr l'espace - n'abuse
mans et c'est pour ça que nous dit quand
il parle de militants culturels c'est
bien cela c'est que avant de pouvoir
demain revendiquer sociaux cela il faut
d'abord qui est de la fierté ou les
fiems à tous les fans avoir avoir de la
volonté de bouger oui si mou de pays
plais pas bon et là où bush ne bouge
comme ça
parce que tu es capable
rougemont d'un petit fiat est
le problème du système colonial ou
impérialiste c'est que lydie d'abord où
les noirs aux lives in ovo pas rien
pour faire court et dans le deuxième
dans un deuxième temps le minimum
les pense comme ça s'appelle le déni de
soi les mêmes il ressent l'icom pas bien
comme pas bon comme inférieurs étaient
fallait justement refaire tout un
travail ou sur le moon lynn à une autre
image d'abord de lui-même l'image de sa
culture de son pays et donc ceux de boot
ou dresse on peut avancer les mots me
crois que dix cas quand elle était
capable de participer cette prise de
conscience là
je comprends pas ce que et en quoi ces
actualités cette méthode disque accord
cette façon d'agrémenter de tous quelles
que soient ses origines
en quoi ses contemporains parce qu'il ya
d'autres combats il ya deux méthodes de
chemin et on voit ça ça peut intéresser
cette autre génération que la vôtre
parce que le combat qui consiste à
s'aimer à se trouver beau bien dans sa
culture sans peau temps de refermer ne
peut très bien être profondément
réunionnais et mais comme pas possible
de klein et notre culture créole nous
souhaitons ouvrir sur le monde mais pour
être ouvert sur le monde qu'on fasse il
coulait bien même est ce un combat
permanent passion un espèce de système
au sénat la mondialisation oussama un
espèce de coca lisation de la culture où
ça peut mener pareille et les importants
justement de revendique aujourd'hui
toutes formes de diversité toute forme
de deux
différences parce que ce qui fait la
richesse et la différence
la richesse de l'autre non enrichi dont
notre
parole apporter au monde participation
au concert universelle c'est de se dire
voilà ce que j'apporte par pour ce que
je suis par rapport à mon identité
créole mon pays la réunion et ça ça
reste contemporain par saoulez toujours
ravagé où koné passion les créoles sous
les français souleymane bah sur les
chinois ce à quoi un peu tout ça mais il
faut fait le buzz en vocal vous fait le
buzz en bocal bien c'est un combat
permanent des fois des fous même parce
qu'il faut williams comme les filles
aiment notre métissage vous nous y
sommes nous tenue de mélanger faut nous
dire mucine dire que ben nous peut être
bien ici à voir les tellement dans
la tête on regarde très loin dans le
ciel très loin dans le monde et c'est ça
qui fait rien nous donner un exemple
parce que le djing et vivant sans wii ne
gagne les mélanges et oui mais ça ira ce
fragile et cette capacité à dire - les
réunionnais nous et même une métisse
mais capable de de faire en sorte que le
monde n'ait pas fait de différence
mais mes deux de mélange de
reconnaissance mutuelle c'est ça qui
rend le combat toujours permanent ce qui
était qu'aujourd'hui chacun tente à sa
manière de trouver son chemin à la fois
elle est ancrée dans localement dans le
particularisme tout est donc tout en
étant ouverte l'universel